berzelius
so i play such a cheese
i can always at least always
play what leads to a funny position
at least sometimes that's how
we get the main variations
playing like everyone
yes there are a lot of moves too
so i'm going to try it like this here
a total harakiri attack in a ludicrously
not so
harmless way
idea is just there 5
yes that was slow or something a4 is now
slow and i think the cd 6 who also
c6 was interesting
yes that is of course
just subtle
knight draws and had bishops
so that he doesn't go away with them with 28
so I could have made six now because I could
still sacrifice the quality but
I mean it always
comes through if I don't even care how I calculated I didn't do anything but actually it always works
if nothing  specifically against it,
so to speak, you do
n't say
yes, it was, it's possible,
then we'll take it away again, we have
now nothing less
and taking it is still very
dangerous
i am also i could have just moved
away and then there is one
i can do now
but just think again runs looks
gone tumor hands
now it has two works i can
still  hitting her
that works too first goes in
and he can take it because she
doesn't have to a tedious but
that helps now he
also takes the field two away
so
maybe springer springer r
500e 43
well
anyway the opening is always
funny well then  three then there really is
a spot
but train
for the once the people were very
hardened that this classic was
the game follow along e3 because there you go
so often against stupid
attacks mattner like this time even back
then
I probably will again
reported the computer fraud or something like
that he just pulled forward
without thinking too much
that works and since you're there  with not
too 29
well maybe you should
bring the pizza team more often the opening